hi my name is Becky and today I'm gonna
ask to tattoo artist to draw my dream
tattoo let's see what they come up with
[Music]
hey what's up my name is Tabatha mara
I'm a tattoo artist from Los Angeles
California
Oh my tattoo I saw is a more like a new
traditional Japanese I from Japan so I'm
strong in that my name is Jose Herrera
I'm a tattoo artist from Long Beach
California doing like American
traditional with a little bit of you
know traditional influence like very
illustrative Sal I'm pretty confident
that I can I give her something that
what she's looking for decently
confident I feel like I'm gonna make
deal with the time that we're giving it
and just make whatever I can
appropriately well see what you want I
feel okay I have a lot of tattoos and
holding my tea is that hard I just don't
know how to conceptualize it that's what
I need them for there's this musician
named Dave Hoss
who is kind of punk rock royalty in my
opinion he taps this part of Americana
it's like lower middle class piece of
people who are kind of marginalized in a
weird way and they don't really get
their voice and they often struggle with
impostor syndrome when they finally do
grow up and get a job and that's been
really important for me because I grew
up in a lower middle-class family and
now I am an attorney some days I look in
the mirror and I'm like you're still
that kid who's always in like dirty
Dickies and hasn't brushed her hair in
three days it's been really valuable to
me to see like someone else go through
that and speak about it the line that I
really want to focus on is and I learned
to wash the dirt off in the rain yeah
I'm always gonna be the dirty kid and I
may not wash it off in the traditional
way and like sometimes that's gonna be
dancing in the rain with like my friends
or my dog and kind of really embracing
that piece of who I've been my whole
life even now in this current role well
we're gonna put that would probably be
either like the back of my right calf or
somewhere on my left thigh okay I like
the idea of a graveyard because the idea
of like washing the dirt off with the
rain coming up from a grave would
theoretically make a skeleton dirty I've
been thinking about this lyric since the
album came out last year and I have not
been able to figure out how to put it
together let's give it a shot
trying to get at it yeah yeah let's go
do this huh yeah so I gotta keep my mind
she wants to do some Americana style
over tattoo so I want to keep dying my
mind why I draw it just make sure it's
appropriate to what she wants to sort of
dancing skeleton with that sort of
graveyard scene and just make sure to
incorporate the lyrics as she finds
really a dear to her heart
yeah it's pretty unique you know the
idea itself it's just very personal so
you can have to cater to like making
sure you catch all the bits that the
person likes you know
so in the beginning you just rather yeah
basically just the idea you know on the
bottom I have to kind of just play with
it a little bit so with the lighter
pencil I always kind of lay out like
what a foundation for the drawing then
you know what I like and what I don't
like starts to like come to the surface
and I can still make pretty drastic
changes
[Music]
all right you know it's kind of getting
there cool I'm having fun too sure
definitely it's a good challenge it's
like working but not at work it takes
time
yeah because you know it's something
that lasts flower we don't you know just
stick it on more you know that father
you are and there's so much to learn
there's no like stopping point it just
kind of just keep going one of the
coolest things about it's people are so
different in so diverse you can get
inspired by all kinds of different stuff
no matter what style they do you know
[Music]
[Music]
mine
I'm the challah turnout and I love the
composition and it looks final and like
mine so yours is great man look at how I
like your graveyard better than mine
it's more subtle man I wish I can draw
like this now we'll bring Becky back in
to see what she likes best this is the
idea that I think will be good on your
back of your calf yeah that's a really
good composition cuz it fits the length
there and like width wise it's really
pretty and then once it's a mom shade
it's gonna have to yeah that's a very
kind of field yeah you know the design
here's mine of course
oh no but see like this is so
interesting because this is like really
good for kapha this like fits like the
thigh really really well so that is
really well composed for that and I
actually I really like the less subtle
graveyard to look at me I'm not a very
subtle person the composition of what
you guys took from me is really
fascinating cuz this one fits so well on
the back of the calf and this one would
be so good on the thigh like especially
like but like meat right there on the
haunches this would look so good I think
I would probably pick this one but
that's because I really like the kind of
graveyard and the symbolism within that
and the skeleton is kind of something
that I'm bringing into that part of it
and this one got the lyrics in there
which was really important to me because
I want to make sure that when I show it
today if he knows that like this is how
he has made this effect on my life these
are both so amazing anyone would be so
lucky to get tattooed by you guys if any
of you have the opportunity to do it do
it you're gonna be in good hands
yeah I would be lucky to have either of
these on my body
[Music]
you